[Music]
coffee
after that interviews have a lot of
questions like why do I have my
surfboard at a lake that's nowhere near
the ocean and what's this weird don't
thing that you and gaps are living here
I'll start off at the beginning I have
my surfboard here because I'm waiting
for a permit from the government which
will allow me to surf
amongst other things when recording the
sauce convinced I'd get a permit in time
but it still hasn't come through so I
guess it's cook time on the lake for me
until the next club it's freezing cold
far away from the ocean if you watched
our last vlog you have seen if you went
Sun argued god of it that's an idea if
you watch my last vlog you would have
seen that we were staying at a house on
the beach which was awesome but we had a
move out of a firstly it was in a place
called misty cliffs so it was really
misty that doesn't sound like it that
doesn't sound bad but the Sun Oneiros
say I'd like one o'clock in the
afternoon it was really cold and it was
torture not being able to surf being so
close to the waves and I was driving
gabs mad so he decided to be best to do
a trip inland away from the ocean that's
why we here that's what takes me to the
next point
don't dome and you take you through how
rad this place really is I'm gonna get a
much better more attractive just
all-around more awesome guide gaps
[Music]
you look amazing
come on in just to make sure that gabs
isn't accidentally
fell naked since she's always walking
around in the nude and I can figure it
out I've made these scents and signs
it'll save me tons of time and toast
[Music]
geez know what the Twitter this is the
open-air kitchen the office or dan likes
to call his studio with a view this is
the best boss ever sighted my favorite
reflection sponge
Dan's favorite reflections but the
alternative perfection spot nature on
our doorstep can you get the very the
bride shower with you
gabs didn't want to do this one but
there is a toilet in case you were
wondering there it is welcome Todd don't
just say I'll bid supposed to be the
launch because always stands turns
around a big mess and nasty thermic that
was awesome
usually I'm not too big on drone shots
but this place is one of those special
places that you actually need to show
where it is with a dry but I don't have
a drone because if you watched the last
vlog you'll see that my drone landed at
the bottom of version however I do have
a plan maybe you're supposed to say no
you always have a plan that's right I do
buzz this thing so pop-pop is a South
African term that means flat it's also
delicious traditional dish that's served
with burbles my plan was simple to take
a line of ten PBC pipes and connectors a
GoPro duct tape and a wetsuit connect
all the pipes attach the GoPro to the
top and then head out to mimic a drone
shot
[Music]
but I quickly realized that my plan had
failed horribly
and I couldn't get it stable or nearly
high
[Music]
so the next day I hiked a nearby
mountain with my zoom lens to showcase
just how secluded we are it's time for a
tattoo story where this week I'm gonna
tell you the pretty sweet story about
how and why I got this pineapple tattoo
before I tell you gabs has always wanted
one so I'm gonna tattoo her first we
have finally reached the point in our
relationship where she clearly trusts me
enough to hand it on
[Music]
damn
but yeah gaps handled that like a champ
it's not easy to get a tattoo here this
is probably the hardest place I took
much longer than I thought so the
meaning behind the pineapple okay so the
story goes like this
I just dropped out of film school hungry
for a project with grit I was really
into channels like Vice at the time I
then met this girl in Amsterdam a great
scriptwriter
and together we decided to embark on
making a film based on a true story a
story about drug trafficking back in
South Africa I befriended a man who
would traffic large amounts of narcotics
across the borders from Peru back into
South Africa I ended up learning a lot
of you answers from him and weirdly
enough started to the frame in there was
something about him I understood anyways
he earned a non-operational tattoo
parlor as a front to launder money out
of and one night after interviewing him
in the parlor I saw this post on his
wall that said be like a pineapple stand
tall
be proud wear a crown and even if you're
a bit of a prick on the outside remain
sweet on the inside always it made so
much sense to me right then and there
not to judge a book by it's cover
especially because I think I'm a bit of
a prick on the outside when I'm socially
anxious but rarely went on the inside
I'm pretty sweet I think so then we
called in some guy to tattoo it on me at
like 3 a.m. that morning I just want to
say obviously I don't condone laundering
money or drug smuggling
just as a role filmmaking scriptwriter I
remain open to really try and understand
all different kinds of people but in
saying this it doesn't mean that it's
right or more incorrect
I then took a walk down to the pier and
reminisce about the days that I could
serve
[Music]
okay I have to share this with you we
could read cabs is doing this is why I
love this woman she is farthing and
Brian at the same time I'm just gonna
jump in the bath and then let's sign
this vlog out I just have one last thing
to say this video is not sponsored at
all but I am working together with an
organization called Africa masks for all
where the goal is to get really good
masks to the people that either can't
afford them or can't get access to them
gabs and I've already donated to the
organization and it could be amazing if
you could - if you want any more
information about it I'll put it as a
top link in my description and go and
check it out it will all be in there
other than that you're awesome and I'll
see you next week and then start just
beginners it easy